- [Interviewer] All right, Slim Diamond.
- Absolutely.
- [Interviewer] Slim Diamond,
where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- I was born and raised in Selma, Alabama,
born in George Washington Carver Projects,
delivered right there at 134C
by a midwife in the late '50s.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
You had both parents?
- No, I didn't.
I knew my father, knew of my father
but he was never in my life.
My mother, and uncles, and
grandmother, and aunties,
raised me and I had a pretty
good childhood regardless,
you know what I mean?
Never wanted for anything
and stuff like that.
It was pretty great.
- [Interviewer] And how
did pimping come to you?
- It started off, I started
off as a hustler first.
I went from hustler, to
player, to pimp in that order.
I started off selling weed as a teenager.
When I was 17 years old,
I got into a relationship
with my high school teacher.
And that went on for a while.
And after that same year,
I mean, the teacher,
she used to give me money
like I'd never had before,
sex like I never had before.
You know what I mean?
And that relationship
lasted the entire year.
You know what I mean?
That school year.
But at summer, I was still 17.
I went to Detroit, Michigan with my aunt
and that's when I met a
34 year old prostitute.
I was still 17.
She was double my age and
she gave me my first...
The first money I ever
received from a prostitute
was in Detroit, Michigan.
She was 34 years old.
- [Interviewer] How
many girls did you have
in your stable at one time?
- The most girls I ever have at one time
was five prostitutes.
I had a lot of different chicks
that did different things
with me at that same time.
But actual prostitutes
the most I've ever had
at one time was five.
Other chicks that I had
with me at that same time,
we were like, every chick,
they're not cut out to
be a good prostitute.
You know what I mean?
Some of 'em were just hustlers.
And I had boosters.
I had girls that used to lift things,
go into clothing stores and
boosts and stuff like that.
But at one time,
the most prostitutes
I've ever had was five.
I was five deep at one time.
- [Interviewer] And sometimes
these girls are doing things
other than just sex for money, right?
They're, they're...
- Oh absolutely.
You know, all of my chicks were thieves.
You know what I mean?
I trained them to be thieves.
I trained them to peel
tricks like a banana.
You know what I mean?
I wanted 'em to strip 'em butt naked.
Every once in a while,
a chick may have like a good client
and it wasn't feasible for
them to try to take him
for what he had because he
was paying 'em too good.
And they was just blew
a good trick like that.
But cats just running a meal.
Cats that they would
meet out on the blade,
out on the track, stuff like that.
Hey, you may not never see this cat again.
So take him, strip him butt naked,
and take it for whatever he had.
And that was just a regular thing
in the pimp game with prostitutes.
- [Interviewer] Did you
have any role models
or anyone that helped you?
- Oh yeah.
- show you the ropes,
starting out?
- Absolutely, you know I had cats,
everywhere you go in this country
in this world from coast to coast,
you're gonna have prostitutes
and you're gonna have
guys that they mess with,
you know prostitution is the
oldest profession in the world.
You know what I mean?
And one thing about that is like
even you're a common
housewife, every, I like that,
I see it like this, Mark,
every chick got a little bit
of hoe in them, every chick, I mean
even the common housewife,
you know what I'm saying?
And what I mean by that
is like from an early age
from early on, females
are taught, the value
of that little snack box
that they have down there.
You know what I mean?
And their parents, either their mother
they learned this thing
from their mother their
aunts or their relatives
or neighbors or whatever like
that, that to use that sex
or that snack box as a
bargaining tool to barter
and trade for the things
that they want to need.
And they also been taught to use that sex
as leverage in a relationship
in any relationship.
That's your basic, your common housewife
or any female, any female,
I don't care whose wife she
is, what position she hold
what titles she hold in life.
They all use sex as a means of leverage.
And also as a means
of reward when you bring home the bacon
and when you pay those bills,
they would reward you with sex
and they may even give you a little oral
on your birthday or some,
if you're a square or lame,
they hold that back for
certain special dates,
when you bring home the bacon you dig?
And also they'll use sex
as a means of punishment,
when you don't, you dig?
They will lock them legs
on you and you get nothing.
I don't care how or what you're doing.
If you stop bringing home that
bacon, that common housewife,
she will lock them legs on you.
You won't have anything
coming, Jack, believe that.
So that's why I say
that all women have a
little bit of hoe in them.
You know what I mean?
That prostitutes,
I like to use the word prostitute, but
in my world we use the word pimps and hoes
and pimps and hoes need love
too, you know what I mean?
So that's why basically
these women choose a cat
like me, a cat of my caliber,
which is a rare breed of cat
because we the only type cats
who'll accept what they do
and actually encourage them
and help them to do what
they do even better.
You know what I mean?
The average cat, a lame
or what we consider a square or a lame.
He's not gonna want her
to share that snack box.
He want that thing all to himself.
As a matter of fact, he'd get mad
and might even want to kill
her about her own genitalia.
You know what I mean?
So they attracted to a
certain caliber of cat
and that's the pimp.
- [ Interviewer] So would
you have sex with your girls?
- Oh, absolutely, some of them.
I have had chicks though,
Mark, that I never touched
I have gotten tons of
money about at a chick.
And to this day, I've never touched them.
I wasn't attracted to all of these chicks.
In order for me to want a chick,
I don't care what kind
of money she bring in,
she's gonna have to be some,
someone that I'm attracted to
or a chick that I like,
you know what I mean?
And some of them it was just
strictly business, like that.
And some of them didn't
even hang around long enough
for me to do that,
to think about having sex with them
because the name of the
game is copping blow.
You know they come and go on.
You know what I mean?
They come in the front
door, looking for the back.
You know what I mean?
So the thing ad a pimp, what
I would do is grind them out
for as long as I had them.
You know what I mean?
I knew exactly what they need.
And that was to bust that
concrete til they toes bleed.
Keep them out there on it,
you know what I mean?
Encourage them to do what
you're doing to keep them active
in the game.
- [Interviewer] And so they would give you
a hundred percent of the money.
- Pardon me?
- [Interviewer] They
give you all their money.
- Absolutely, I didn't do no negotiating.
I didn't make bargains or deals.
No compromising, all the cheese.
I'm paying all the bills.
I'm taking care of the chicks.
I'm making sure that not only
she's fed, clothed, housed,
but her kids as well, a lot
of these chicks got chewers
and it wasn't mine.
You know what I mean?
And even sometimes their parents,
we had to break them off.
You know what I mean?
Some of them parents that
knew what I was doing
they encouraged them to
stay with me because I
was a good cat.
I'm not saying that I didn't
put my pimp hand down.
Sometimes I would have to
get physical with them.
You know what I mean?
And lay pimp hands on them
and bless them with an ass whooping.
That was just part of the game.
You know what I mean?
When they violate, you dig?
Because I rule with an iron
fist, you know what I mean?
I didn't tolerate insubordination
from my chicks period.
You know, I'd rather see them
go, you know what I mean?
Than to hang around me
and violate my rules and
regulations of my game.
You dig?
- [Interviewer] And were drugs a part
of the picture for your girls?
- Pardon me now?
- [Interviewer] Were drugs
a part of the picture
for your girls?
- Some of them did drugs
but that wasn't something that I condoned,
my whole thing was to get them off drugs,
Mark, you know what I mean?
I never was a pimp to
get a broad by means of drugs,
cause when you do that,
you're not the pimp, the dope is the pimp,
you know what I mean?
And so a pimp that does that,
that's a scavenger pimp.
You know what I mean?
He's not pimping them at all.
Like I said, the dope is pimping them.
You've got a chick out here on the blade,
as soon as she get up,
get the money she's gonna
run to the dope boy.
She not gonna bring that money to you.
She gonna, you're money
always gonna be short.
So, but I have, especially
down here in LA, when I was
knocking chicks down here and pimping it
out of these different hotels,
they didn't have a track.
Sometimes we were running broads
right here on seventh street.
But I was mostly mackin out of hotels,
the Cecil, the Hayward, the Huntington,
the Raz and the Frontier,
the Terminal, I was putting broads
down and stuff like that, doing things,
a lot of these chicks,
some of these chicks had cocaine habits.
Some of them had heroin
hadicks, I mean heroin habits.
And some of them had crystal meth habits.
You know what I mean?
And I would always try to
take them away from that,
and when they wouldn't
adhere to that and try to get
some treatment or whatever, get some help
then they just had to go
because I couldn't stand
to keep them around
like that because they
were intolerable, man.
It's hard to deal with these type chicks,
but I tell you one thing
from experience that
I had better dealings with
heroin addicts, females
than I did with crack head chicks
because it was just no telling
no understanding with those chicks, man.
So no, that wasn't part of my game.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] And what about you?
- I've done drugs.
I've done every kind of drug it is,
you know what I mean?
You know, cocaine, heroin, crystal meth,
I've smoked sherm for a while,
but I've been clean now
for almost 20 years.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- Absolutely, 20 years, I kicked
that, you know what I mean?
And and I've been had a
better life ever since.
That's what actually kept
me at the penitentiary.
I started going, as
long as I have been out.
Now, this is the longest I've been
out of the penitentiary
systems, seventies, man.
I started going to jail in the seventies,
in the late seventies,
you know like I said
I was a marijuana dealer at that time.
I never sold narcotics, heroin or cocaine.
I started off as a cat
selling weed down South.
And I ended up getting
a trafficking case when
I was in my early twenties.
And they gave me 15 years
down in Alabama for that.
And I ended up doing
seven years down there.
And I did three years
and four months out here.
So for collective 10
years and four months,
actual incarceration time.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- Absolutely, I had a chick
that I got my kids by,
I got three sons by a chick
and she was not a prostitute
but she was a hustler.
She was a top grade A hustler and she
brought it in and she
did what she had to do.
She was a booster and she
was a top-notch hustler,
she sold weed for me and
different things like that.
And when I went to penitentiary, man
she stood by me and she
risked her life for me.
She took care of my family.
She risked her life for me by
smuggling drugs into prison.
For the, I was in prison
the first time, three years.
And this chick did everything
in the world to help me
and like I said, risked
her life and freedom.
And so when I got out, like I said
I already had three kids by her,
I felt okay about marrying this chick,
and I married his chick, we
went to her preacher over
at his house or on Church
Street down in Selma,
Reverend Shannon and just
did it just like that.
And to this day we're still married.
You know what I mean?
Even though, and she knew
everything that I did
and we'd never got a divorce
we've been separated now 20 years
but we stayed together almost 21 years,
that chick and I, and I loved her,
you know what I mean?
And I've loved a lot of different broads,
I mean I've loved some of my prostitutes,
like I say, pimps and hoes need love too,
you know what I mean?
And it was like, it wasn't a square love,
it's a different kind of love,
it's pimp hoe love, you know.
And that's what it is,
you know what I mean?
But pimps and hoes need love too
and I definitely had
love for several of them.
I think maybe about
three in my entire life,
women that I actually
cared emotionally about.
I try not to get an emotional attachment,
and a lot of pimps do
get emotional attachment
but they try cover that up and
keep your feelings in check.
But it'll slip up on you
man, you know what I mean?
And you'll find yourself
loving these chicks,
you know what I mean?
You're having deep
feelings for these chicks,
you know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] What's more
important to you love or money?
- [Slim] Well, I mean, I like money, man,
you know what I mean?
I got to have money because
we gotta have that to survive.
I've done like so much
time, incarceration time
and I did that without love.
But even in there you got to have money.
You got to have somebody
putting money on your books
you've got to have
money to pay your bills.
You know what I mean?
So love takes a backseat to getting cash
to getting cheese and cheddar, you dig?
So you've got to have your money, man.
You know what I mean?
But no life is complete without love.
I always got love in my
heart, for my fellow man,
for anybody that I've dealt
with over a period of time,
I get emotionally attached to them,
that's just my nature.
You know what I mean?
Everything is made from love.
- [Interviewer] The laws
have changed drastically
since you've been doing it.
- [Slim] Oh, absolutely.
- [Interviewer] And is
that why you've kind of
gotten out of the game?
- [Slim] That has something to do with it.
That's not in totality, but
like the penalty is too
great for me to even think
about doing it, I'm in
my early sixties now.
And I couldn't see one thing I learned
like when I didn't want to be a old man
in the penitentiary doing
time, because I first went
to prison when I was in my early twenties.
Like I said, I did prison
time in early eighties.
I went back did prison
time in the nineties
and I did three years of time
in the early two thousands.
So a chunk here, a chunk there
my life looking like Swiss cheese.
I got holes all throughout my
life, you know what I mean?
My absence from my
family and my loved ones
I lost loved ones while
I was incarcerated.
So yeah, the laws have changed greatly.
The got a new thing,
the Palermo protocols
you may have heard of it, where it's
for suppressing human
traffickers and child molesters
and kidnappers of women
and stuff like that.
And, but I like to say off the top
that human traffickers are not pimps
and pimps are not human traffickers.
You know what I mean?
I'd never kidnapped a broad.
They said things gotta be by,
the whole game has gotta
be by choice, not by force.
You know what I mean?
But according to the Palermo protocols,
however you do it,
by force, fraud or coercion,
you can't even, encourage
a chick to do that.
because they they'll get you
by force, fraud or coercion.
And I learned that from
a cat out of Chicago
named King Bert, he the
one who hipped me to that,
in a documentary he did.
I had never even heard of that.
And I'm still out here
active doing things.
And it's stuff that you need to learn.
You need to, pimps or
any cat in their life
need to read up on these things.
You know what I mean, to
see what these charges are
because they're associating
us with human traffickers
and the times that
they're giving pimps now
is the type time that
they would give someone
that's actually a human trafficker.
Someone that's kidnapping
chicks and kidnapping babies
and young girls and
putting them out there.
But I got to say to me
that's not pimping, that's mis-pimping.
You know what I mean?
Well even though you have a reputable pimp
you got some reputable pimps
who mess with underage chicks.
But like I said, that's not
pimping, that's mis-pimping
And when they get caught
for that type of violation
I don't have no sympathy
for them when they'd go
and have to do that kind of time.
You know better than
to mess with a 15 year
old girl and stuff like that.
Oh yeah.
But other than that, yeah, the
chick has got to choose you.
That's why we call it choose.
She gotta come with a choosen fee.
You can run behind a chick, all you want,
that's in anything, even
in a square relationship
ain't nothing gonna work
unless the chick likes you.
You can beat her head into the ground.
You can whoop on or whatever,
if she don't like you
and don't want to be with
you, it's not gonna happen.
It's gotta be by choice,
not by force, but there
and that's what we used
to use to like, justify
justify and rationalize,
our actions with these chicks, somebody,
people think we're monsters
and stuff like that.
You what I mean, and
say hey well you know,
you exploiting and manipulating that chick
but this chick, see prostitutes,
like I said, that's the oldest profession
in the world, you know what I mean?
And, wherever you have
prostitutes you're gonna have guys
that they like and love
and want to be with
and they're gonna have to
give that money to this guy.
Because other than that,
why's he gonna accept her?
You know what I mean?
So yeah man, it's gotta be
by choice, not by force.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] What's the core
of the pimp and prostitute relationship.
Is the girl trying to recreate
the relationship she had
with her father or is
it something like that?
- In some instances of the chick.
- [Interviewer] They call
you daddy a lot, right?
- Yeah, and some cats
really get off on that.
You know what I mean?
But it's nothing to me for
a chick to call me daddy
because I see that as
game, you know what I mean?
They be trying to ease up on
you, daddy this, daddy that,
like I say some cats eat that up, but it's
it's not something that,
and some cats even demand
that the chick call him daddy.
And in some instance,
like back to your question
some of those broads do
want a father figure.
And they look to the
pimp as a father figure
you know what I mean, a
pimp is her everything,
you know what I mean?
Not just a father figure, but her lover,
her guide, her spiritual
advisor and everything.
And that's what you want to be to a chick.
You want to be everything like that.
But like I said, a lot of time when they
when they come with that, it's just drag.
You know what I mean?
The chick, and they know they use game
to play on our emotions too.
You know what I mean?
Like a chick call you, Hey,
daddy, you feel good about that,
it makes you feel good.
So it's accepted when I could dig it
and some in the past some called me that.
But most of my chicks just called me slim.
- [Interviewer] And what
are you proudest of?
- Pardon me now?
- [Interviewer] What are you
proudest of in your life?
- Getting myself together and,
trying to live a better life
for my family and for my
kids, you know what I mean?
Coming up from not
being a criminal anymore
see everybody got the right to change.
You know what I mean?
I had been, see I've been
a criminal all my life
since I was a teenager.
I started off at 13, 14 years
old boosting outta stores
and then about 15
a friend of mine, Rock Joel,
he put that weed sack in my
hand, I started selling weed
at 15 and by 17 I was a player.
Like I said, I'd knocked
my school teacher first,
and I had a relationship with her.
She paid me.
She was the one that
gave me my re-up money.
You know what I mean?
It was a grocery store
across the street from where she lived.
And I would go to the grocery
store with her to shop.
She would buy food and stuff for us to eat
and the people in the grocery store saw me
with the school teacher and
they got, so for me, we made,
that she would write me
checks when I was 17 years old
and I'd take the checks over
there and cash the checks
at the grocery store,
you know what I mean?
And get money from this lady.
You know what I mean?
So, yeah, you know.
- [Interviewer] You must
have some interesting
stories for me--
- Oh yeah absolutely but let me finish
with what I was saying
about being a criminal
or like everyday, Mark,
for most of my adult life
every day that my foot
hit the floor, every day that I woke up
and my foot hit the floor,
you can best believe that
there were gonna be multiple
felonies that were gonna be committed
every day of the week,
every day of the year,
I was a career criminal.
I mean talking about felonies
that could get you penitentiary time.
You know what I mean?
And that's all I did my entire adult life.
I had a job here or there,
but that just wasn't my bag.
You know what I mean,
working on a square job.
That just wasn't my thing.
Everybody that knows
me can attest to that.
You know what I'm saying?
But just like Malcolm X said,
there's no disgrace in being a criminal.
You know what I mean, at
having been a criminal,
the disgrace is to remain
one, you know what I mean?
And Malcolm X himself had been a pimp
and a criminal and all that
before he converted to Islam
and got his life on the right track.
Not like I'm trying to
follow Malcolm X or anything,
I got my own life and I got my own thing
but I'm proud of the fact
that I was caught up in a
trend of un-accomplishment.
I'd see I was gonna do something today,
say I was gonna do
this, I want to do that.
And I'll never do it.
And finally, when I went to prison
the last time I completed that, a book,
I wrote a book and that's
what I wanted to do.
And I wanted to,
not write a book about how to pimp,
not a instructional
guide, to being a pimp,
not a Mack Manual or anything like that,
but just write a book.
See my story is a cautionary tale.
I don't try to encourage anyone to go
into the life and I don't try
to encourage anyone to get
out of it, just do your thing
but do it the right way and
be a man at what you're doing.
You know what I mean?
Because see the thing about the pimp game
whatever you touch also touches you,
you know what I'm saying?
So here you are, you think
you playing the game,
but the game is actually
in reality playing you,
you know what I mean?
So do your thing, but always
try to be the best at it.
And not the most abusive cat,
not a gorilla pimp and all that
trying to force issues,
'cause you get washed up out
here in this game like that.
So I'm proud of the fact
that I changed my life around
and trying to be a little
bit more productive
in that I'm able to pay my bills
without having to be a criminal,
at this age, in the game,
you know what I mean?
Who wants to like,
another cat, a great cat I
like to quote, Muhammad Ali.
He said that if you catch
a cat in his fifties,
they're still doing the
same thing that he was doing
in his twenties, man, that
cat hadn't grown at all,
no growth at all.
You know what I mean?
He used 30 years, you're
doing the same thing.
You stuck on stupid.
You stagnated, you stymied,
you stifled, stuck on stupid.
So that's not something where
I wanted to be like that.
I wanted to be able to excel and grow,
as a human being,
'cause there's more to
me than just a pimp.
You got to first be a man.
That's the title, pimp,
hustler, mack, the izm,
whatever, subtitles,
which is cool, you dig.
But you got to be a man,
and so that's my goal,
to be a successful human being
a successful man, not just
for myself, but for everybody
who loved me and cared
about me and my family,
my kids, I got grandkids,
and I just want to be a
better Slim Diamond, you dig?
So that's what's up, Mark.
- [Interviewer] Awesome,
Slim, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Man, I appreciate that.
And I got so much more to tell,
but I like to say this before I go, that
for all you cats out there
there's three types of
people in this game.
Those that make things happen.
Those that watch things happen.
And those that wonder what happened.
Therefore you either got to lead someone,
follow someone or get the
fuck out the way, you dig?
That's Slim Diamond, for the record.
Mr. Slim Diamond, Hollywood
Division, palms up, chuch!
- [Interviewer] All right Slim, thank you.
- Hey man, I appreciate you, man.
Was that cool?
- [Interviewer] That was awesome.